[Música]
el aeropuerto internacional de kabul
volvió a una cierta normalidad con la
operación de vuelos después de que la
terminal viviera ayer una jornada
dramática con miles de personas tratando
de huir y dejando por lo menos cinco
muertos entretanto el talibán anunció
una amnistía general para todos en
afganistán y pidió la participación de
mujeres en su gobierno
el presidente de eeuu joe biden enfrenta
una ola de críticas tras defender su
decisión de retirar las tropas
estadounidenses y culpar a los líderes
locales por el colapso del gobierno
afgano desde el partido republicano
califica en la salida de los soldados o
bajo el liderazgo de bailén como
desastroso
y en haití se complican las labores de
búsqueda y rescate tras el terremoto
luego de que las fuertes lluvias de la
depresión tropical grave cayeran en gran
parte del territorio las autoridades
haitianas aseguran que hasta el momento
hay al menos mil 419 personas fallecidas
y unas 6.900 heridas
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si revelan que
como siempre un gusto acompañarlos
comenzamos después de una jornada
caótica en la que al menos cinco
personas perdieron la vida en el
aeropuerto de kabul intentando dejar
afganistán las operaciones aéreas se
retomaron este martes un primer vuelo
con franceses evacuados aterrizó ya en
abu dhabi el talibán mientras tanto
avanza con su agenda y anunció una
amnistía en el país los insurgentes
dicen también que quieren que las
mujeres estén en su gobierno aunque en
la comunidad internacional persiste la
preocupación por el futuro de las
afganas el informas de juan pupiales
la comunidad internacional sigue con la
retirada de los suyos de afganistán este
martes en aviones como este del ejército
francés los vuelos retomaron en la
capital afgana después del caos del
lunes bajo control estadounidense la
terminal se ha convertido en la
esperanza de miles de personas para
abandonar un país que vuelve a estar
bajo el control de la más estricta ley
islámica 640 afganos abordaron el lunes
un avión de la fuerza aérea
estadounidense con destino a qatar un
reflejo del éxodo en el país en donde el
futuro de las mujeres sigue siendo una
gran preocupación
fuimos al aeropuerto pero regresamos
porque la situación era mala en el
aeropuerto y todo el mundo tenía miedo
de una llegada sorpresiva de los
talibanes
mientras tanto los insurgentes avanzan
con su control sobre kabul el talibán
anunció este martes una amnistía para
aquellos que trabajaron en el anterior
gobierno y dicen animar la presencia de
mujeres en su administración pese a que
defienden la aplicación de la 'sharia'
la cual atenta contra los derechos del
sexo femenino desde la onu ponen en duda
estas promesas de ser women dicen que
las mujeres pueden trabajar y que las
niñas pueden ir a la escuela tales
compromisos necesitan ser honrados y de
momento teniendo en cuenta el pasado
estas declaraciones son recibidas con
algo de escepticismo
sam's que
pese a la toma de los talibanes en
afganistán
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
defiende esta retirada que según lo
planeado debe completarse para final de
mes después de dos décadas de
intervención
para analizar lo que ocurre en
afganistán bajo el control talibán le
doy la bienvenida a mi lejarza esta lxi
analista internacional a mí gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 el
grupo talibán asegura ofrecer una
amnistía en el país y además insta a las
mujeres a participar en su gobierno que
tan creíbles son estas declaraciones
existe una verdadera voluntad de cambio
oeste es una fachada solamente para la
comunidad internacional
es un placer estar aquí bueno en lo
referente a lo que el régimen talibán
dice incorporar la postura de la mujer
dentro de lo que viene a ser su
administración es justo lo que decía ya
el alto comisionado el portavoz alto
comisionado de derechos humanos de
naciones unidas se recibe con
escepticismo por el pasado por supuesto
pero sobre todo por hechos es decir nos
gusta siempre intentar ver las
demostraciones por parte del régimen de
arriba en lo que se ha visto es que
efectivamente la imposición de la sharía
desde la manera tan rigorista que los
talibanes la entienden donde las mujeres
tienen que vestir con el burka donde las
niñas no pueden salir tienen que salir
de la escuela de los diez años y hasta
pueden casarse antes o ya una vez hayan
salido de la escuela y ponerse a
trabajar en algunos casos depende de qué
tipo de trabajos
deja deja mucho entre entrever ese tipo
de dualidad frente al hecho de que la
mujer vaya a estar en la administración
afgana qué tipo de mujer
qué tipo de desarrollo de la mujer se va
a permitir dentro del país es algo muy
importante
personalmente y desde un punto de vista
a futuro lo que se suelen tener por
perspectiva es una estrategia de
propaganda es decir es una forma de
entrar en el poder es una forma de
consolidarse con promesas que habrá que
ver si tan reales son como ellos dicen
pero personalmente hice un han
demostrado es muy difícil hablemos de
esa consolidación porque estas
declaraciones del talibán han sido
interpretadas como señales positivas en
países como rusia y también turquía que
tanta aceptación tendrá este gobierno
talibán en la comunidad internacional
bueno efectivamente los líderes o los
programas potencias regionales va a ser
turquía pakistán china rusia irán y
qatar ya han reconocido al régimen
talibán ha querido nombrar todas porque
es muy anecdótico que son países que
tienen también en general buenas
relaciones entre ellos
en este sentido a nivel internacional se
está empezando a ver con mucho
escepticismo porque la postura de eeuu
ha llegado hasta decirse que puede que
eeuu para que se haga una transición
pacífica y no se repitan errores del
pasado ni derramamientos de sangre pueda
llegar a reconocer al régimen talibán
para que no se produzca por ejemplo un
colapso de refugiados esto no tiene
ningún no tiene ni pies ni cabeza la
realidad es que estamos hablando de un
grupo armado que sigue teniendo lazos
con grupos terroristas como es al qaeda
y eso no va a cambiar tocaba un punto
muy importante y es el de los refugiados
que podemos esperar en medio de esta
crisis humanitaria en las próximas
semanas hay especial preocupación por
quienes huyen del país y por una nueva
posible crisis de refugiados con la que
europa dice que no está lista para poder
lidiar con ello
efectivamente desde europa es muy
complicado lidiar con esta crisis y al
final anteriormente comentados ustedes
en el noticiero que bueno que los
republicanos atacaban a bailén esta
forma tan desastrosa la única otra forma
de haber hecho esto hubiera sido hacerlo
más paulatinamente durante el tiempo y
que los refugiados hubiesen salido
igualmente entonces europa sigue sin
estar
dispuesta no dispuesta tanto sino más
que nada preparada los países de
alrededor como es irán como es pakistán
o como serán turquía que serán los
principales receptores de refugiados los
van a aceptar muy probablemente pero no
van a poder tampoco
asimilar esta este gran volumen de miles
de millones de perdón de millones de
personas que seguramente intenten salir
y aquí hay que entender otro factor
fundamental en cuanto a los refugiados
los que puedan permitirse llegar a
pagarse un viaje como hemos visto con la
crisis de refugiados sirios
y hasta hasta europa y los refugiados
que no puedan llegar y que tengan que
vivir en unas condiciones infrahumanas
porque prefieran eso a tener que estar
bajo el yugo talibán
complicada la situación en afganistán
amén gracias por estar aquí con nosotros
en france 24 que tengo usted un feliz
resto de día estados unidos anunció 500
millones de dólares en ayudas para los
refugiados que tengan que escapar de
afganistán como ya lo estábamos hablando
tras la retoma del control por parte del
grupo talibán esto después de que el
presidente de bailén defendiera su
decisión de retirar sus tropas del país
una decisión que le ha valido una oleada
de críticas por parte de la oposición
republicana veamos
calificó la caída de kabul en manos de
los talibán de desgarradora pero joe
biden se mantiene firme en su decisión
de retirar las tropas estadounidenses de
afganistán culpa a los líderes afganos
después de que el presidente hasra fanny
lu hiera del país
los líderes políticos afganos se
rindieron y huyeron del país los
militares afganos se derrumbaron a veces
sin intentar luchar en todo caso los
acontecimientos de la semana pasada
reforzaron que cualquier implicación
militar
ahora era la decisión correcta
nuestro right station tras las escenas
de afganos desesperados abarrotados en
el aeropuerto de la capital en busca de
un medio para huir hayden se comprometió
a ayudar a los que habían trabajado con
los estadounidenses durante el conflicto
de dos décadas y que ahora podrían
enfrentarse a las represalias del grupo
insurgente
entretanto en territorios aún y desde
los republicanos también critican la
retirada la califica de precipitada y
mal preparada a pesar de que donald
trump fijó una fecha de salida aún más
temprana para las tropas de
estadounidenses si insiste en salir al
menos podría haberlo planeado
un desastre total lo presenciamos en la
pantalla gente aferrada a costado del
avión desesperada tratando de salir de
allí porque saben que van a ser
asesinados por los talibanes porque
estaban colaborando con nosotros tras el
caos de los últimos días biden se ha
visto obligado a enviar tropas de
regreso al país para asegurar el
aeropuerto y más evacuaciones llevando
en total en terreno alrededor de 7.000
soldados baiden advirtió que si los
ciudadanos estadounidenses son atacados
por el talibán eeuu responderá con una
fuerza devastadora mientras tanto los
afganos se enfrentan a un futuro
aterrador una vez más a merced del grupo
militante
cambiamos ahora información la población
afectada por el terremoto en partes de
haití espera la ayuda humanitaria
necesaria en las tareas de rescate que
se complican con la llegada de las
lluvias de la depresión tropical grace
en el país ya hay más de 1.400
fallecidos y 6 mil 900 heridos a causa
del terremoto de magnitud 7.2 el día
sábado varios países de américa latina'
contribuyen a la respuesta humanitaria
carolina a los alleo nos cuenta más
buscan ayuda entre las estructuras
colapsadas quienes sobrevivieron al
terremoto esperan hallar entre las
ruinas alimentos para garantizar su
subsistencia
miles de haitianos esperan por ayuda
humanitaria los países de américa latina
fueron los primeros en solidarizarse
chile envió 16 toneladas en medicinas
kits de higiene comida y agua los
chilenos
sabemos y conocemos lo que significa un
terremoto devastador y lo que significa
en términos de sufrimiento y dolor para
las personas que tienen que vivir esas
adversidades y por eso tenemos todas las
razones del mundo para hoy día
acompañar solidarizar y ayudar al pueblo
haitiano en este momento de tanto dolor
y de tanta angustia méxico por su parte
envió toneladas y artículos de primera
necesidad a los insumos se suman los
equipos de búsqueda que apoyan las
tareas de rescate colombia envió 30
personas para ayudar en las labores
mientras que las autoridades haitianas
prometieron evitar los errores de 2010
cuando los recursos fueron dirigidos a
ongs que no brindaron la respuesta que
se esperaba nuble
queremos una mejor respuesta que la que
se dio al terremoto del 2010
el camino y toda la ayuda de afuera debe
ser coordinada con la agencia de
protección civil
la isla aún no se recuperaba de la
destrucción causada por el sismo del
2010 además enfrenta este desastre en
medio de un turbulento ambiente político
exacerbado por el asesinato de su
presidente job en el mois el 7 de julio
y a continuación repasemos la situación
de la pandemia y nueva zelanda eeuu y
uruguay
la primera ministra neozelandesa sin
adrián ordenó el confinamiento por tres
días de los más de cinco millones de
habitantes del país tras detectarse un
solo caso de contagio en la ciudad de
auckland el primero desde el pasado 28
de febrero la medida se da ante el temor
de que el caso detectado en un hombre de
58 años sea con la variante delta
el gobierno del presidente
estadounidense joe biden planea anunciar
que casi todos sus ciudadanos deben
recibir una dosis de refuerzo de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 8 meses
después de haber sido inmunizados esto
supone una nueva fase en la campaña de
vacunación que podría comenzar a
mediados de septiembre y en uruguay
cerca de 1 millón de personas se han
inscrito para recibir también una
tercera dosis de la vacuna de facer
contra el hobbit 19 el gobierno del país
está ofreciendo el refuerzo a aquellos
que fueron inmunizados con las dosis de
la vacuna china sinovac
y cambiamos nuevamente información el ex
presidente colombiano álvaro uribe
ofreció su versión sobre los falsos
positivos como se conoce en el país a
las ejecuciones extrajudiciales de
civiles presentados por el ejército como
bajas en combate uribe se reunió con el
presidente de la condición de la verdad
el sacerdote jesuita francisco de ruth
el ex mandatario aseguró haber sido
engañado por los soldados y dijo que su
gobierno actuó con celeridad y también
transparencia ante las denuncias de
dichas ejecuciones extrajudiciales fue
durante su mandato entre 2002 y 2008 que
se adelantó la llamada política de
seguridad democrática en la que se
ofrecieron incentivos a los militares
para que entregaran resultados según la
jurisdicción especial para la paz en el
país hay por lo menos seis mil
cuatrocientos dos víctimas de falsos
positivos y el 70% de estas se dieron
durante la era del ex presidente álvaro
uribe escuchamos sus declaraciones
los que me vengan a decir que como yo
exigen resultados iban a cometer
crímenes
por favor la culpa nunca es de quien
exige resultados con transparencia y el
incapaz criminal que para fingir
resultados que para fingir resultados
produce produce crímenes
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continúen con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias muy buen día para todos
[Música]
siempre que hay un líder asesinado
tenemos que pensar quién se beneficia
mujeres que preparan